the rays have beaten the indians 11
consecutive times and tristan mckenzie
will be our northeast ohio four dealers
starting pitcher mackenzie will be
making his 13th start it'll be his sixth
start at home looking for his first win
at home
on the ground deep short grabbed but no
play
rosario got over there short but had no
chance to get a rosarita who's on with
the infield hit
well against austin meadows up there
with men in scoring position
[Applause]
and that's down to third
and end up within his throw to first
now rosarina will score
and the raves take the lead one nothing
and another go-ahead rbi for meadows
six and four on the year
he's
been out of the pen a few times but
mostly 14 this is start number 15.
against the indians he's 2-0 in his
career 219 a.r.a two appearances just
one start and both of them have appeared
right here cesar hernandez leading it
off
that ball's driven to deep center field
back is phillips he will wave goodbye
and we are tied at one
that's the fifth lead-off home run of
the year for cesar hernandez and a
career-high 17th overall
there's a ball high pop to left
shallow and the sun is going to be a
problem it's going to drop for a hit
and a rosario will stop with a
sun aided single
take a look at what mckenzie's been
doing today
yeah watch the
third baseman the change of the zones
for mackenzie
there's the curveball and a couple of
against a couple left-handers you see
the right-hander getting to chase that
fastball up troy went down on the
breaking ball down got four strikeouts
just one walk gandhi diaz scorches one
to center back goes bradley zimmer what
a catch
full extension on the dead run that ball
was sailing over his head
and he made a dynamite play to take
extra bags away from yandy diaz
yeah that's definitely a double no
question he's his timing was uh just
perfect
that ball right over his head he wants
to take another look at it on the
scoreboard and i don't blame him because
that ball is tough
started to come back over his head with
the timing
just beautiful
that's a double
now this one shot the other way toward
the corner that's going to fall for a
base hit ramirez with a pickup throws
going to go to second and franco in
standing up
so franco doubles the other way against
mckenzie his third double of the
year that's a lighter the face hit into
right charge by mercado
and putting on the brakes bronco at
third base
how does that happen
i mean it wasn't like that ball was
absolutely laced wander franco out at
second base should be getting a pretty
good secondary lead and with two outs
you're running on contact
so that absolutely should have at
worst been a play at the plate
second and third two down in the 02
pitch struck him out
cruz shoots this one into center field
that's got carrion is gone
home run to center field off the bound
of nelson cruz and the rays take it two
to one lead
number 21 for cruz number two
in a raised uniform
right field and it's sinking and a
diving catch by mcconnell
oh there's the center fielder playing
the corner outfield spot today
laying out a beautiful swan dive to take
a hit away from yandy diaz the second
time an indian's outfielder has flat out
robbed him has been efficient though you
know no more than 16 pitches no wait 15
pitches in any any by mercado give him
some credit there
two out single keeps the inning alive
there goes the runner
pitches high and the throw not in time
so mercado with a stolen base it's his
third
and a runner in scoring position with
two outs and now a 2-2 count for roberto
perez
2-2
and it's skyed into right toward the
line a bit
and oh gonna make the catch just as he
got to the track a rosarina hauled it in
and that retired the aside had it all
the way
rbi tripled by jose ramirez there's a
ground ball single in the right field
diving attempt by wendell
but he couldn't reach it
there you go you got your lead off man
aboard
him
[Applause]
two on with
nobody out yeah there it is he tried to
throw that fastball in and got a piece
of the hand uh rosario
harold ramirez making his way to whole
plate as ahmed heads down to first
shoots it into right field to base it
cesar coming around third sarbaugh waves
him home on his way to third with the go
ahead red of man rosario it's a 2-2 ball
game as big harold delivers here in the
eighth
live ball center field plenty deep
enough here meyer settles under it
tagging is ahmed rosario he's coming
home with a go ahead run the throw not
in time
and it's a 3-2 indians lead bobby
bradley with rbi number 22.
emmanuel class say
his job has come out to get that first
out it will be the bottom part of the
order he's got wander franco joey
wendell francisco mejia do up
jammed him broke his bat
he's there in time for the flip
one away
four balls
and one strike away from getting
the second out
[Applause]
stayed with the slide piece
two down
[Music]
left field
ramirez
makes the catch book it the indians
finally beat the rays snapping an
11-game losing streak to tampa
as emmanuel flossay works a 1-2-3 night
for his 12th save of the year
james karachek is the winner he's now
7-2 out of the bullpen
and with the victory the indians go to
49 and 48
salvaging the finale of this four game
series
and tampa will leave town at 60
and 40.